down in Florida Tucker Carlson may be
gearing up for his own legal battle as
he broke his silence after being fired
Monday
the former number one cable news host
flashed an ear-to-air grin saying quote
retirement is going great so far I
haven't eaten dinner with my wife on a
weeknight in seven years
when asked about the future his response
appetizers plus entree it's widely
speculated Tucker's termination relates
to damning messages uncovered during the
Dominion voting systems lawsuit
investigation there were a lot of other
messages that were still being kept
secret I believe there's material in
those private messages that gave Fox a
reason to remove Carlson well focus on
the leaker not what he leaked among the
lead Tucker Tech's Fox News doesn't want
you to see he called a former Trump
attorney a highly offensive sexist slur
he also blasted his Fox News division
colleagues as being quote pathetic just
didn't care I still don't also speaking
out Tucker's former producer Abby
grossberg who's in the process of suing
him and Fox News for creating a hostile
work environment an allegation the
network says has no merit Tucker and his
executive producer really were
responsible for breaking me and making
my life a living hell so there is a
feeling of Justice us we're told Tucker
has hired the same pit bull attorney as
fired CNN anchor Don Lemon he was also
spotted out for the first time in New
York City Lemon wearing a baseball cap
and shades was out shopping with his
fiancee this morning former co-anchors
Caitlin Collins and Poppy Harlow carried
on as a Duo good morning everyone and
last night poppy made no Mention Of The
Morning Show shake-up When She
interviewed Kim Kardashian at the time
100 Gala would you ever consider a life
without the cameras yeah absolutely I
would be just as happy being an attorney
full-time
[Music]